aujourd'hui le président macron a appelé
et a parlé pendant une heure et demie à
monsieur poutine pourquoi pour qu'ils ne
restent pas isolé dans son coin
absolument pour qui est toujours un
dialogue établi qui ne soit pas enfermé
dans sa bulle à devenir de plus en plus
paranoïaque et ça ça fait partie de la
division oui mais oui mais général
général donc ce que vous dites c'est un
peu comme comme quand on est face à un
forcené et conflits on va garder le
combat qu'il faut c'est du sang et or
alors que c'est tout différent moment il
va dire je vais aller du bon côté ou
bien je vais aller du mauvais côté dans
le monde sait ça s même ce que vous
dites là vous nous rassurer encore une
fois c'est vrai que la raison va tu nous
as quittés parce qu'on se dit mais
combien de fois lorsque vous parlez un
forcené ça marche oui bien sûr ben
wallace et si c'est non mais attendez
comme vous le disiez je pense pas qu'ils
soient fous je pense qu'il a des
effectivement des lubies les visions par
ailleurs un oeil à queue leu leu covic
qui a touché beaucoup de monde elle a
touché lui parce qu'il est resté isolé
pendant deux ans dans son coin et c'est
pour ça qu'il faut lui parler c'est pour
ça qu'il faut avoir le dialogue avec lui
et l'avantagé avec mac on sait que il
décroche quand convaincront de maiden
lui téléphone ou quand les chinois lui
lui téléphone et décroche tandis que
pour certain une fois ils lui disent
côté ailleurs justement parce qu'on l'a
dit la fin le président chinois et lui
dit quoi vladimir poutine ce qu'on sait
que il voit là la chine et la russie ils
ont de très bonnes relations il lui dit
quoi parce que c'est quand même aussi
une des clés de la fin du conflit ce qui
se passe entre le président chinois et
le président russe non mais c'est vous
avez raison c'est une clé très
importante mais les chinois initialement
n'ont pas critiqué l'action russe en
ukraine seulement le chinois pour
survivre dans l'économie mondiale ils
ont besoin du monde parce que l'économie
chinoise a le fonctionnent qu'avec le
monde et donc d'une certaine façon ils
sont en train de se dire aujourd'hui le
camarade poutine y va un peu loin quand
même lui va et isolés nous on n'a pas
envie d'être isolé donc il temporisait
d'ailleurs dans les dernières décisions
à l'onu ils se sont abstenus ils n'ont
pas dit non se sont abstenus donc là
aussi il faut raison garder oui est ce
qu'on peut imaginer ce que vous avez
évoqué deux généraux qui étaient
présents avaient coûté mais ce qu'on
peut imaginer que l'armée se retourne
contre poutine alors moi si vous voulez
c'est un peu l'espoir que j'ai
aujourd'hui non seulement pas des jets
de l'armée je ne sais pas mais le peuple
russe sergey il me dira peut-être mais
ne voulait pas cette guerre non et les
images qui viennent petit à petit très
bien
instrumentalisés par les ukrainiens
qu'ils font très très bien à des chars
détruits des morts des blessés etc vont
commencer à marquer la population russe
c'est le premier point le deuxième point
c'est que le premier cercle autour de
poutine s'ils seront que here is y avoir
un problème et une perte de pouvoir ils
préféreront éliminer le président pour
garder le pouvoir absolu mais ça c'est
quelque chose qui peut jouer en faveur
d'une certaine rationalité dans cette
crise parce que finalement qui lui
l'intérêt du peuple russe à cette guerre
aucun aucun aucun nom mais il est très
grand il n'ya pas le territoire on en a
trop
il ya un autre et un autre point
important on en parlait tout à l'heure
sous les oligarques voilà c'est ça
peuvent aussi aux impressions très à
venir dans le style je pense que ça
c'est vraiment très très important
l'importance que ça va guérir de la
mairie qui ont ils on peut partir de la
générale oui mais ce que je dis quand je
parle du premier set les gens font
partie la ligue 1 c'est parce qu'à un
moment il perd énormément d'argent
sachez le tous les jours ils perdent dim
quand je vous dis car c'est des millions
ou des milliards dow et donc forcément à
un moment et vous dire bon ça c'est ça
et puis la mêlée mais il va falloir
qu'on va falloir siffler la fin de
il ya vraiment là dedans une guerre de
communication je parlais de la
communication des ukrainiens qui la font
très bien la communication russe
aujourd'hui va perdre un peu pied par
exemple dans l'aujourd'hui devrait comme
une création du président poutine
vis-à-vis de la population il faut
qu'ils montrent qu'ils négocient d'où la
négociation qui a lieu aujourd'hui qui a
abouti à rien du tout mais c'est pas
grave ça lui permet de dire voyez moi je
veut négocier sont les autres qui sont
des méchants mais au bout d'un moment
tout ça ça ça touche ses limites quand
même